STARTING LINEUP BROUGHT TO YOU
A
SHOT, MIGHT HAVE TICKED OFF OF
KOSKINEN THERE.
[ Booing ]
>> Jack: THE CROWD WAS LOO THE F
CONTACT, HE COULD HAVE STOPPED
CARTER HART, A ATTEMPT, A GOOD ,
G
THAT PICK UP. MIGHT HAVE BEENS E
ONE WHO HAD PUSHED THROUGH THAT
PAD, RIGHT THERE, FOLLOWING IT ]
[ Cheering and Applause ] THAT M
OF THE ---ERS ARE TRYING TO SELA
OSKAR LINDBLOM.
AND LINDBLOM WAS DENIED.
>> Jack: THE GIROUX WRAP, ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Jack: PLAY, FEATHER-SAUCE PUN
INTO THE DANGER ZONE.
FIND ANOTHER WAY, OFF OF
HAS PHILLY REGAINED THE LEAD
3- CLICHE
IT IS HIS SIXTH OF THE YEAR ANDT
IT IS COMING, TAKING THAT STICK
OF ATKINSONART.
COULD NOT SNEAK IT FIVE-HOLE.
PULJUJÄRVIEATS, CENTRES IT.
THAT ONE-TIMER, SHOT RIDE OFF OF
TIED WITH 103
THE OILERS AS PHILADES NOT DOWN,
SAVE MADE BY KOSKINEN ANDD!
KOSKINEN!NEN KEEPING THE
♪]
REBOUND, KEITH PINCHING, CAUGHT.
EDMONTON, 3.
WHAT A THERE.
THIS PASS, BANG, UP THE ICE AND
THE CLOCK.
>> Jack: AND IF YOUN THE PLAY.
THIS IS A SITUATION ROOM